[Musique]
quel que soit vos sensibilités
esthétiques artistiques ou créatives je
pense qu'on peut tous être d'accord sur
le fait que ceci est une œuvre d'art
maintenant si je vous montre ça je pense
qu'on est à peu près d'accord toujours
c'est une œuvre d'art
et si je vous montre ça bon on peut tout
à fait débattre impressionnisme grande
révolution dans l'histoire de la au gros
besoin
ça reste de près ou de loin de là
maintenant si je vous montre ça
ouais je suis pas sûr de faire
l'unanimité rigolez pas trop parce que
les auteurs sont dans la salle ce soir
et pourtant ça pourrait vous surprendre
mais tous ces exemples ils ont un point
en commun je vous assure
c'est la créativité
alors là je sais ce que vous pensez et
non je vous rassure c'est pas un gros
mot ce soir je vous emmène en quête de
votre créativité
mais d'abord c'est quoi la créativité
je vous préviens on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge parce que définir la
créativité
de René Descartes à David Hume en
partant par Emmanuel Kant définir la
créativité ça déchaîne les passions
depuis des centaines d'années à la
croisée entre psychanalyses philosophie
art et sciences elle semble encore et
toujours nous échapper
j'ai passé les 20 dernières années à
essayer de développer d'appréhender de
comprendre le créatif qu'il soit bien ou
collectif personnel ou professionnels
j'ai tout essayé lorsque j'étais enfant
je passais mon temps à dessiner à
chanter à jouer des pièces de théâtre
pour mes parents créer des fausses
publicités avec mes voisins de paliers
et encore aujourd'hui je travaille avec
des artistes des comédiens des designers
et s'il y a bien une chose que j'ai
compris au cours de ces 20 dernières
années c'est que la créativité elle ne
se définit pas
elle est en chacun de nous inépuisable
et accessible à tout moment
et à tous
et je dis bien à tous
mais si je fais un petit sondage avec
vous ce soir est-ce que celles et ceux
qui se considèrent comme des créatifs
pourraient lever la main
ouais bon clairement on est à Dauphine
je pense qu'ici on maîtrise tous mieux
Excel que la dernière technique de
peinture à l'huile
mais ce que nous avons tenu ce soir
n'est pas surprenant
en 2018 la Nesa a réalisé une étude sur
plus de 1600 enfants âgés de 4 à 5 ans
et ils ont étudié le potentiel créatif
de ses enfants sur une échelle de la
pensée divergente alors qu'est-ce que
c'est gros mots c'est évaluer le
potentiel des participants à répondre à
un problème de manière innovante ou
alors face à un objet de trouver des
utilités
et ce qui me fascine avec cette étude
c'est que sur les 1600 enfants âgés de 4
à 5 ans il y en a 98 98% qui sont
arrivés au niveau de génie créatif
donc si on réfléchit un peu ça veut dire
que vous avez quasiment tous ici était
des génies de la création
c'est formidable
papa totalement parce que sur les mêmes
enfants cinq ans plus tard et ben ce
nombre déjà il tombe à 30%
et encore 5 ans plus tard toujours les
mêmes enfants le même test mais ils sont
plus que 12%
et vous devinez à l'âge adulte ils ne
sont plus que 2%. alors comment
arrive-t-on à un résultat aussi de
rester je me suis posé la question et
pour moi c'est évident qu'il y a d'abord
un contexte institutionnel on est des
enfants très créatifs à l'école et on
nous apprend qu'il ne faut pas faire
d'erreur qu'il ne faut pas se tromper il
faut surtout pas s'aventurer dans des
eaux dangereuses et puis au-delà de ce
contexte institutionnel il y a aussi des
normes sociales qui nous accompagnent
dans notre développement
surtout à l'adolescence de manière
positive ou négative et qui façonnent
notre vision du monde nos valeurs notre
conscience de nous-mêmes et de nos
talents surtout
et puis au-delà de ces structures
institutionnelles et de ces normes
sociales
il y a vous vous envers vous même
j'ai eu cette discussion avec un ami
dauphinois l'autre jour et il m'a dit
cette phrase extraordinaire c'est tout
de même incroyable que la source c'est
tout de même incroyable de rester
prisonnier de ses précédents succès au
point où ils deviennent la source de nos
futurs échecs moi aussi j'ai eu du mal
la première fois
être prisonnier de ces précédents succès
au point où ils deviennent la source de
nos futurs échecs
assez précisément dans ces moments-là
que retrouver sa créativité originelle
et primordiale
nous sommes des êtres mortels illimités
mais nous avons avant tout cette
capacité extraordinaire et merveilleuse
à penser le monde
concevoir le monde mais aussi le
redéfinir le transformer grâce à notre
créativité
je pense que nous pouvons tous être
d'accord ce soir laisser libre cours à
sa créativité c'est difficile nous
sommes avant tout le premier juge de nos
talents
mais la créativité ce n'est pas un luxe
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
je n'apprends rien au plus dauphinois
d'entre vous
la créativité dans un contexte
professionnel c'est absolument
primordial notre génération évolue dans
un monde de plus en plus complexe qui
fait face à des avancées technologiques
sans précédent et non ici je ne parle
pas à utiliser tchat GPT pour votre
prochain rendu organisationnel
IBM a réalisé une étude en 2010 sur plus
de 1500 PDG à travers 60 pays dans le
monde
et ce qui me fascine c'est que la
créativité est apparue comme l'une des
compétences les plus importantes pour
assurer la réussite et le futur d'une
entreprise mais avant tout c'était un
moteur pour les employés à être plus
motivés plus engagés et surtout plus
épanouie
mais ce soir c'est le plan personnel qui
m'intéresse
parce que votre créativité c'est votre
meilleur arme pour traduire votre
imagination dans le réel
cela peut prendre des formes classiques
jouer d'un instrument écrire dessiner
pourquoi pas pratiquer la danse le
théâtre le cirque et puis des fois moins
classiques comme apprendre ou pratiquer
une langue étrangère
bon et puis pourquoi pas créer une
start-up innovante on reste à Dauphine
tout de même
ce que je vous invite à faire ce soir
c'est repartir en quête du génie créatif
que vous avez été et qui sommeille en
vous encore en ce moment même
et pour cela j'aurai trois choses à vous
dire
premièrement et c'est une bonne nouvelle
la créativité c'est pas un talent c'est
pas un don mais c'est aussi un travail
et un travail régulier Stephen King
écrit 3000 mots par jour peu importe la
qualité de sa production Mozart et
Beethoven ont tous les deux composés
plus de 600 œuvres au cours de leur vie
alors que la plupart de leur
contemporains n'en composé que 100
deuxièmement n'ayez pas peur de l'ennui
l'ennui c'est génial chéri c'est le
parce que c'est quand vous vous ennuyez
que vous avez vos meilleures idées donc
faites vous plaisir pendant votre
prochain cours de comptabilité et
laissez votre esprit vagabonder
et puis enfin troisième chose continuez
de faire ce que vous faites déjà parce
que ça veut dire que vous êtes le
meilleur
par exemple Andy Warhol lui avant de
devenir l'un des plus grands artistes du
monde de travailler dans une agence
publicitaire
si je dois vous donner une ébauche de
réponse ce soir sur se créer la
créativité je vous dirai ceci
cultiver une plus grande conscience de
soi développer son empathie et établir
une relation plus profonde entre le soi
et le monde
la créativité avant tout c'est un appel
au rapprochement au-delà de nos vécus et
de nos consciences héritées au-delà de
nos cultures et de nos identités
alors ce soir s'il vous plaît en sortant
de cette salle n'ayez pas peur de faire
des bêtises
d'apprendre des erreurs que vous allez
commettre de vous prendre les pieds dans
le tapis s'il le faut parce que c'est ça
avant tout la créativité c'est être
audacieux
et ça aussi c'est l'esprit de
l'Université Paris Dauphine
merci
[Applaudissements]